hey guys you are watching steam punks
the show where we dig through the latest
releases on steam and find you some
hidden gems my name is Jess I made me
train and without further ado you'll
probably know games like Skyrim VR came
out this week that's not it no no no
it's a pretty obvious Jim I think Skyrim
was significantly in the headlines but
uh these four games you're gonna hear
about now aren't so ed why don't you
start us off with your first alright so
the first game I play this week is
minutes this is a black and white 2d
Gameboy Zelda style RPG with a twist and
it's a it's from a sort of any developer
supergroup which includes one half of
Vlambeer famous for a nuclear throne and
all those kind of games and music by
Yukio Kaleo part of my pronunciation who
wrote the music behind the Vlambeer
games as well so it says all the style
adventure we start in your house and you
find this sword which is cursed and
causes you to only exist in the world
for one minute at a time that's 60
seconds before you die and find yourself
back in the house ruff so you can't get
very far at first but you'll discover
quests that you can do which will give
you things that will upgrade your
capacity to overcome obstacles so the
first one for example needs you to kill
five crabs for the bar owner who then
gives you a cup of coffee which allows
you to push boxes and fortunately the
items you collect and the quests to
complete within that minute persist
across deaths so you're constantly
squeezing the most out of every
60-second life you have to grab that new
item or get that new home checkpoint
they'll push you even further and
there's an instant death button so if
you find you've taken a wrong turn and
you haven't optimized your run and the
rest of your life is sort of a bus you
can just kill yourself respawn it's lean
and it's very very quick the game as a
whole is very tightly designed and it's
got a really great sense of creativity
to its entire design so I from the items
to the characterization to the little
sounds that the characters make when
they speak it's also you've just got a
nice sense of human to at all so it's
really pleasant to go through and sort
of see what is on the next screen so on
my first run-through of this game I've
finished it in just under an hour but I
realize that my completion was like
really low there are so many hidden
secrets and items that aren't strictly
necessary but I legitimately
to find and use to keep on exploring
further and further
yeah so that's minute minute is $10 on
Steam it's also available on ps4 and
Xbox one if you do have a PC and it
comes highly recommended from me yeah
looks great
he's so cute is he human he's not a
human is some sort of duck thing and I
shouldn't mention that your two main
tools are a sword and a watering can
Wow well so you just told us that your
the two tools you use in the game all
right what is throw it in a watering can
right or well your two pals in the game
adventure pals that I play are a giraffe
and a rock cool I like both those things
so this is a really nice daljeet kind of
platformer it's kind of got simple RPG
mechanics like when you get enough
experience you get to get a bigger bag
to put more items in or like a doc cells
ask death spirit to keep your coins
which you lose if you die but on the
whole it's it's quite easy and it's very
accessible your main goal is to hunt
down rubies to pay back a ransom to this
evil dude after who has a plot to turn
people into hot dogs okay he kidnaps
your father this looks and sounds a lot
like adventure time
oh yeah okay sir I reckon it's somewhere
between adventure time and it's also
reminds me of Steven universe a lot yeah
like Cartoon Network's yeah so it's like
it's it's very sweet it's very colorful
it's definitely like got a lot of little
funny moments also the animations are
adorable he freaks out if he goes too
close to the edge of a platform he looks
like he's gonna fall off it's also got a
very simple I'm owed type soundtrack and
it's got kind of like an open cup head
of sort of map where you go from stage
to stage and also go into little towns
where people give you a quest the quests
are crazy simple as are the little
puzzling elements where you need to
unlock the next area but it doesn't
really matter it's kind of just a game
you jump into and have a good time
there's nothing halting your momentum so
it's kind of fine that nothing is overly
complicated at least in the beginning
hour or two that I've played when you're
hunting around levels you can get
collectibles which are cupcakes and when
you get enough cupcakes to fill
Tinh you feed them to a fat cat who
gives you skins which is great sounds
good so you can you get skins to like
wear like a planter box as a hat or I
got one that turned my rock into a
battery okay yeah okay things happen in
this game it's very quirky it's very
goofy so adventure pals is 15 bucks
people who played a lot more of the game
then I do say it goes for around 15 to
20 hours the campaign but that seems
like pretty good value for money to me
[Music]
all right so you just played a really
nice accessible platformer how do you
feel about a PvP mobile well yes this is
a MOBA but don't go away yet because
it's actually not bad
so this game is MX Shrike it's a free
mobile and I played a lot of mobiles in
my time I've got like $700 and dota and
I hit max low in heroes of the storm and
yeah this is a MOBOT but it's also
really fast and fun and action-packed
compared to those ones and it has the
potential to be a lot sort of easier and
quicker to get into because it's a 1v1
or a 2v2 mobile with real time strategy
components that the classic MOBA tenants
are all here so the main goal is to push
towards your enemies base and destroy it
I mean they're a towel is along the way
that attack you and you need to attack
and overtake to sort of game map control
and there are regularly spawning creep
which are sort of weak minions that
spawn occasionally and push towards the
enemy base regardless of what you do and
you take control of one hero or mech and
you earn currency to sort of buy things
but that's kind of where the similarity
is kind of in each mech has a sort of
different abilities and stats so you
have your four set of abilities but they
all transform into planes which is their
common thing and they all have either
arranged or a melee attack and they all
kind of control like you're playing a
shoot-'em-up there's also a big RTS
component to this here so the credits
you steadily earn can be used to build a
variety of support units um like tanks
artillery some extra soldiers which you
can deploy in the battlefield to beef up
your pushed into enemy territory so you
pick them up and you can fly them around
the map and put them anywhere you want
and sort of give orders to them
like directly you can only order units
that are directly in your vicinity the
maps themselves aren't as
straightforward as your typical MOBA
maps they're not just like three lanes
or one lane
I love the map simpler whiny paws and
alternate routes instead of out out of
the way Towers that you can overtake to
give you advantage that you don't
necessarily have to sort of contest so
MX strike is a primarily multiplayer one
we won or 2v2 games but there are a
number of AI opponents that you can go
up against to unlock more things so
there's a little bit of a campaign here
that said I I played a few multiplayer
matches and got absolutely creamed it's
it there seems to be quite a few people
playing it but like I said a lot of them
have been playing it since early access
and also has sort of dota style boot
boxes sometimes but there's not a huge
emphasis on progression through the
boxes they just let them nice to have
boosters and yeah look I have a lot of
movie fatigue at this point in my life
but the pace of this one and the RTS
elements sort of made it very fun from
the get-go so yeah give it a shot there
are a lot of people playing it so I
joined them and fill out that
multiplayer pool and get creamed
you get creamed
okay so that's very intense let's bind
things down a little let some trying to
think of a train pun and I can't but I
play train valley - okay which like MX
strike great with trains it's not at all
like a mech strike what it is like is a
puzzle tycoon kind of game like every
tight crane game you can pause it you
can have it run at super speed if you
know exactly what you're doing but if
you do that you'll probably have your
trains crash into each other
you can plant at your own pace you can
play it at your own pace so half the joy
in this game is opening up a map and
seeing your little towns you begin with
one and then there's more towns in the
later levels and they all have
requirements of kind of resources that
they need so it's a matter of sending
workers off to the little the mines or
the workshops that make that resource
and then getting that reason those
resources back where they need to be so
you basically want to be clever about
where you're putting down trucks you
need to constantly be adjusting which
way the trains go it's really about
managing tracks and schedules and money
and resources and its really satisfying
when you know what you're doing the
tracks can feel a little janky to build
at the beginning but because it lets you
build tracks while the game is paused
it's not a huge issue so there's things
like you get a certain amount of money
at the beginning and there's tons of
different things especially in the later
levels that you can spend money on and
you need to decide what how you're gonna
prioritize for example there's no point
building a track to get workers to a
sawmill that requires wood to turn into
other kinds of logs if you don't have
wood first so you want to get your
primary resources so then you can for
example you need to get wheat to get
cows and then you get the cows this is
not what I was expecting no it's not
what I was expecting either every time
you create a resource a you create a
stack of wood or you create a pile of
sand one of the workers gets used so I
don't know what's happening to the
people left I think there's a conspiracy
but so you need to constantly be sending
workers over there as well it's really
nice as well because it's taking you
through the progression of the railroad
so you're starting in like a little farm
or like dealing with stuff on the land
and then you move your way towards
levels that are based around like the
Eiffel Tower and a palace and stop in
the city yeah and it gets well it gets
much more complicated okay and the kinds
of resources you have to get get more
complicated and they get harder to get
I'm I'm into this I kind of want to play
it out it's really fun it's an only
access right yeah it is in early access
and it's ten bucks but there's a lot of
content in there I find very little to
complain about at this game it's just
like a really enjoyable experience all
right well I think this train has come
to its final stop thank you for joining
us on this episode of steampunk if you
have any recommendations of games that
we might have missed this week or games
that we should look out for next week be
sure to let us know on Twitter I'm at
Edmund Tran until then we'll see you for
the next episode of steampunks next week
bye
[Music]